thanks so much hey guys welcome to the
world premiere of Star Wars Battlefront
2's multiplayer gameplay assault on
Theed we're ready to show you guys the
live gameplay for the first time I'm
your host
iJustine and with me here today we've
got Golden Boy and Palk esslyn producer
from DICE what have we got going on here
today guys we got a lot going on today
first of all what we're going to see
today is a three stage mode it's our new
game play will be showing the we'll be
showing people going at the joints are
attacking feed they'll be going all the
way up the main the main pathway towards
the Royal Palace they need to escort the
MTT tank from there if we progress the
stage two the droids need to try to
bypass security make their way into the
palace itself if they're successful
they'll be able to take on the throne
room and they're the droids will ideally
try to capture that from the Clone Army
unfortunately the Clone Army still there
needs to try to push them out and make
that last in every just take a moment
here appreciate the fact that we get to
be joins in in Star Wars this is gonna
be awesome
I can't where are you guys excited man
you guys got to come alive over here
because we're gonna see some great
gameplay we have some great great game
changers who are gonna be competing here
and I use competing as a term because
these guys are holding nothing back
Jesse yeah I know it's been super
exciting and we got a chance to play
yesterday and it's just really fun to
sort of get into this environment you
know what's something that we've seen in
the movies we're actually in the game
play and with somebody here who has
actually worked on the game so let's
talk more about what we're seeing here
and getting into this because there's
three phases to this
phase 1 that's right and also we have
some great game changers so one of them
pop up just a little while I was a VF
updates pool shark moose elk we also
have my boy darkness
aka dankness he will be playing as well
we have a wet feet masterji Star Wars HQ
and some NBA LIVE just cuz why not you
know Stuart thanks baby but here you go
so Star Wars Battlefront two folks now
this is awesome because essentially face
one you get two is for density down the
street of beat here and the pressure is
on for the clones to have to hold back
the assault your ball they do definitely
the the joys are sit there trying to
escort that MTT up the main pathway if
they're if they're successful we go on
to that phase two but right now we're
seeing some done some specials gameplay
from my big battle from updates
yeah let's actually talk about the
specialist and also you're gonna see a
couple different classes here this class
in particular that master cheese using
is the heavy class specialist tinier
sniper rifle exactly what did they do so
the heavy class is great they got a bit
more health in your average trooper
they're also able to pop that combat
shield try to push into area so you can
see those guys pushers or defenders in
some areas but looks like we got one of
our vulture droids right now not sure
who's flying this guy but these guys are
great at air-to-air trying to take out
those other ships that might be coming
in that Kaku n1 Starfighter otherwise
you're there to provide some great
ground support like we're seeing here
trying to get some strafing runs in on
those cones oh come on man miss that's
our you just you just did it wrong there
buddy sorry we also do have the air
support we also
do we do so another thing that those air
vehicles are great at is trying to take
out some of the the ground vehicles that
you may see the droid army has the AAT
tank something that's really great at
troops suppression although we see here
a little clip of the V Wing doing that
up man he's just mowing some some droids
down there yeah it's just absolutely
shredding you're gonna see this happened
quite a bit especially in this phase
because there's a lot of open fields
here right and you can just come through
for some great straight great bombing
runs really and eliminate as many people
as you possibly can and also you put the
presence of an air vehicle out there
players will fear the skies and they
will you know look for cover aiming this
map where it's already difficult to find
cover to begin with in this phase
absolutely and you can see right now
that there is an 80 tank sitting around
on the battlefield he is probably taking
out those phone troopers but this this
droid this vulture droids really
stepping it up what I love about this is
everyone's like oh look at this great
open map and then when you start phase 2
is like everything starts coming in and
coming way closer together and we're
talking a little bit more about the
assault class so for somebody who was
just started playing this never played
any previous versions do you feel like
the assault class making for something
perfect for them to pick up I think you
know soul classes yes absolutely it's
something that that's painful these
talks are something that a lot of
players will be able to jump right into
they're your frontline flanker attacker
I think they're gonna be fairly easy you
can get right in and just start having
your typical running gun action there's
their signature ability you see here at
the top of the screen your number two
ability that switches you over to a
shotgun you get a little bit faster and
you're able to really get in there and
kind of you know break those break
through those frontline I love it I love
you
man it is so good and it's actually when
I first used it it really caught me off
guard I wasn't expecting it I said wait
a minute I could destroy people so I
just charged into the room and just
absolutely shredded everyone it was so
fun to play with here we also seen some
great dogs right here between the clones
and the separatist this is certainly
what a lot of folks love in Star Wars
and just really in any game that dice
makes right they just always do a good
job with the air coming he's really
trying to track him down this this
vultures really oh yeah have motor
cannot shake him well we got stars HQ
here you know he's playing he's playing
the assault class again you saw him he
had the signature thermal detonator that
he he'll be able to kind of suppress
some of those guys with as he rushes in
and there are different different
weapons as well like one of the guns
that I would oftentimes use with these
semi automatic gun it you know fired a
lot slower but you can get some great
shots with it and then there's also this
nice compact SMG style laughter that
really shreds through people in close
range
I was Nina you know I think we want to
give me any bit more variety that's not
around you know yeah also some AAT tank
action here and this is that doing what
it does best is suppressing that point
trying to keep those clones out of the
way they're trying to make their way
forward as the jelly buckets can use a
march down he has to get away shortly I
don't know what you try to flank the
tank it's not smart
maybe maybe he will maybe a little
combat role they're gonna give you some
escape options in case you get into some
some hairy action oh we didn't get to
see this one before
finally some ATR tease yes so these are
super great for taking out those AAT so
these guys are little quick they have an
ion charge ability that way they'll be
able to do a little bit more extra
damage against the tanks as they see it
so you can imagine like three or four
things on the battlefield
really rushing around points like look
at this this can pick up someone out
what can you what can you do this yeah
you can watch someone over if you want
okay
oh I was actually gonna say could I get
shot off of it if I'm on top of it
because my body's yeah that was that
question was answered you know almost
immediately yeah almost immediately oh
man so mr. Moussa here you know what for
this guy to be on a tear a little bit
later as well and also I did want to
highlight we had an officer as a matter
of fact right in front of so did one of
my favorite classes what is it about the
officer that makes it so unique I mean
my my twitch bill is aren't where they
used to be I'm slower nowadays but I'm
able to really puff up my class or puff
up my teammates trying to let them get
some extra help let them push me to
points faster and what happened finally
probably some good dog fight it going in
there okay so right in one super rider
what's great about some of these
starfighters is these are access through
our new battle point systems so instead
of finding a pickup token on the on the
map like we used to in the last game
you're now able to defend
whether you're scoring points via kills
via team play assists or you're playing
the objective like we really want
players to do you're earning points
continuously that will allow you to
spend those on whether it be a special
character whether it be a vehicle or
even a hero and the battle points dead
that allows you to unlock all of those
things all those things definitely and
also something to look out for too when
we get into Phase two
that's when battle points are really
gonna play a role there right right
right now definitely you see a lot more
it's an open space you have time for
this air combat is some vehicle gameplay
but once we get inside it's gonna be a
different story
that's right things are definitely to
heat up and what is this happening right
this is a lockout trying to shake him
out yep they better enjoy their air
combat here because that's not gonna be
happening for much longer
oh man destroying him oh nice job I mean
usually what you need to do support his
team right it's that combined arms fire
you want to make sure that somebody's
trying to cover you from the air oh boy
so and you can see after every respawned
as well you get those company points
you're right that's right users later on
got some specialist in play here as well
maybe take off a couple faces perhaps
I'm still in the specialist class you
can also deploy different types of
tracks yeah absolutely so they have
access to a trip arm so if you want to
sit there for body you know that true
sniper character you set up some trip
minds behind yourself make sure nobody
can flank you or really to provide some
of that cover fire
and it's especially hope in this area
because it is such a big open area so
that's specially some really shines more
bombing runs here and just absolutely
tearing him up at the same man who so
gets killing it telling it in this book
yet again it's doing great
oh let me see there uh one of the
officer classes right next to one of the
clothes officer fantastic pushing right
you want to be able to push the
objective definitely support your team
like if you are playing with your
buddies you want to be able to have at
least one officer available because he
keeps you going in the fight at least I
mean they really help push you know when
those heavies are trying to drive
towards a point
you got your officers behind you giving
you some extra help making sure that
you're not you're still able to complete
that push or on the opposite side if
you're one of the joys you feel you to
lock down a point the officers have
access to a turret that they can place
on the ground and you know give it a
little bit more fire support for that
area trying to see massive G here's a
you know he's really focused on the
bombing runs right he's not trying to go
into combat with Musa who's up there
there's a darkness forty nine just
shredding everyone up here maybe I don't
get a couple but why did it you just
went to the beach mode yeah this is
happening oh yes so tell us about the
siege mode well this is how does this
play out in siege mode you for a limited
time you're able to just blow up some
huge area effect shots you lock down the
position but you're able to have a lot
more firepower we also just saw the b2
super battle droid there as well that's
something another one my favorite well
another one of my favorites yeah you can
grab those guys we have the battle point
system those guys great at pushes once
again where they have high health a lot
of rapid fire oh here we go oh there it
is and this big explosion indicates
phase one is over now we start phase two
and this is when the action really
begins to pick up here because it gets
really tight inside of that building and
players need to be mindful of that and
look for this b2 suture
shred through everyone especially with
that cooling ability that he has to be
able to keep him just constantly
shooting in the fight he's gonna he's
gonna make a huge difference he has a
five minutes inside I mean there's gonna
be narrow pathways he's gonna be able to
just shred as soon as anybody gets in
his way
because it snows ignore those narrow
corridors could be trouble and she's
waiting for the prime opportunity to
push up here players falling god you
know Wi-Fi there there oh here we go
this is abnormal action here we go folks
doors which starts to get interesting
this was it scary Darth Maul will excel
in phase 2 and phase 3 actually inside I
mean he's a great mobile attacker he's
gonna sit there with his mastery of
those quarters - oh absolutely I mean
some of his abilities you can see here
he's got that squid attack he's able to
who just rush in and out of combat and
just take eyes out the process was funny
I was talking to himself earlier and he
was using Darth Maul and he was saying
how there's Boba Fett as well I mean he
was talking about how he wishes Darth
Maul pretty reflect it was like if he
could reflect
[Music]
oh brother play that was a good flank
right full of fetch balls
shredded the clone army unfortunately
all this little Fett syllabus battle
Boba Fett is done like a hunter-killer
so if the other if the Clone Army is
able to get some of their heroes in play
like this is where Boba Fett was really
shining with that jetpack in his he's
able to kind of float above the
battlefield fire off some rockets and
really just take out an individual
target what's different
velasca uh the last game we give him a
bit new tricks he's got a new concussion
rocket they literally just Moria players
completely he also has a rocket barrage
instead of just one rocket to david and
really nice nice also one thing to keep
in mind we saw the beat shoot here we go
but on the clone side you know there are
specialists you know characters that you
can pick up as well we haven't seen much
of it yet but that would be the clone
jump schuberth that's right very
different from the standard like assault
class of heavy class it has the jump
Jets that you love from battlefront the
original that's right brought back here
but now focus on the central class
exactly Kara back to boba fett here with
this look at that he's shredding people
just laid out so much firepower content
oh they got no down jesse was able to
find him on that one but here comes some
officer gameplay here oh good finally
something plating support supporting
people matter that you know you gotta
give him something with a linchpin of
the team you know yeah exactly now what
is this - exactly as soon as the healing
of students that yeah exactly it's that
healing a good it gives you a little bit
of buff for your little over health but
it also heals you back up so it's oh we
got some of the the jump troopers oh boy
and here we go it's ready for Phase
three in just a little bit there's a
jump shoot but we talked about them
before jump shooters super fun to play
but again you know it's attached to a
specialist now so not everyone's gonna
have any equipment although what's
really fun in the original battles right
but I'm gonna be excited that hopping to
jump shooter and shred people I mean I
know people we love there's people love
people love to jump at oh yeah we've got
ray
well I I'm super excited to play as her
achieve she's a quite a powerful
character Frost I'm sure you know she
got out of that one really don't run
with me but oh they got her on the Droid
fallen by a finished annoyed sing no but
Ray hasn't Sarah have my HJ hello
absolutely
so Ray's mind trick is something that
against all enemies you'll be confused
for a little bit your controls were kind
of no work against you making you a
little bit more vulnerable to attack
just so you guys know this is when it
gets anything because they there's so
much going on here and hold with that
what's that we saw a little Han yeah
we're gonna get some hot I hope so
but I mean you saw it earlier so every
time you finish a life will show you how
many battle points you have it some
people have enough points good kills
reinforcements especially this late in
the game you'll see a lot more these
special classes coming out a lot more
the heroes coming out so again this jump
super here you know with his rocket
launch with a jump back trying to be
mobile trying to fly into that that last
zone capture point this is really where
heavies are gonna thrive as well and
there is you laying down fire the
doorway just absolutely dominating with
clones they need to put out they need
the fight this went out here there are
so many lives left that the separatists
have to their team they could really run
through this two clones happy
acting fast because if they cap it that
will be in the separatists will win this
game it's not looking so good for my
boys on the corner are me I'm a
separatist so I'm excited I'm just gonna
go on whichever team wins
oh I'm not gonna be too picky here to
the jumping ship I understand that you
know no loyalties maybe you are sin that
maybe I am oh that's fine yeah so in the
third page though in Detroit you're
trying to capture that program so you
can see here if you remember it this is
the main this is the main throne and
this is such super close quarters do you
have any like sort of strategies that
you were dad absolutely I'm just missing
if you're the cones you're hoping that
oh geez I'm soldiers getting torn up
that's gonna be trouble it's like too
soon mana can't relive force awakens
again you know like don't do it
Darth Maul is just destroying absolutely
everything is there any tips to like
taking him down I mean you want to have
a try to combined arms fire Oh the tip
is blasters run away maybe run away run
away shoot the crap out of Darth Maul oh
man who's our MVP look at that nice nuts
up moose out congratulating thirty-six
kills he ended up thinking is my
goodness well guys that was it what did
you guys think intense
not bad actually not I'm lying it's
freaking awesome I love it it's so good
it's like I love the clash based
gameplay personally because again you
can really get your squad your friends
to get together and say like hey I want
to you know run the officer and where
you can run it through some highlights
here maybe not listen that's not the
best eyelet you know because although
maybe it was
oh please just a crash montage I think
that's what we're gonna do at this point
all crashing all the time I'm down with
that but it was new suck I mean you sit
there you know getting as many battle
points as he can before his next life I
mean that's what you want to try to see
if this battle system you want to either
snowball your points keep earning them
keep earning them keep building getting
more for more things yeah and again you
know just to gain one thing I do want to
compliment team on you know a nice just
the way the game is it's so beautiful
especially seeing this part of the Star
Wars universe brought to life the way
that they with you guys really managed
to do so I mean kudos on that one once
again now just drop dropping jaws
everywhere we'll try we try I mean the
team back home is amazing they do
incredible things and you can see it
looks so pretty look just look at this
this laser fire is too tense it looks
beautiful it really does look incredible
so yeah are we discussing right now you
know like we get it the game looks good
oh but that was awesome and overall I
mean you don't have to say like I can't
wait to get my hands on it I can't wait
to coordinate with my friends you know
and destroy the clone scum
I can't let hurt them yeah you know
exactly separatist all day well guys
that was so awesome now if you guys are
in LA you can come join us at fan fest
this weekend and if you come down on
Monday we've got a chance for you guys
to win a trip to Gamescom in Germany
this August all you have to do is come
and play which is I mean that's not
asking too much and you have to be the
best player of your match and you guys
will be entered to win a trip for two to
Cologne Germany and a full two